E aí
[Música]
Oi boa tarde
é incrível está aqui com vocês é
incrível vim aqui falar um pouco sobre o
que nós estamos passando o que virá a
seguir a inevitável falar sobre essas
transformações e eu queria chamar
atenção que um evento como esse é uma
coisa simbólica é o simbolismo da nossa
superação na capacidade do ser humano de
se adaptar então é sobre isso que eu vim
falar o porquê que esse momento tem sido
tão difícil porque a pandemia tão
transformadora por quê que apesar de
toda essa tristeza que nós vivemos com a
Fatalidade com a temeridade da doença
com esse afastamento terrível nós
seremos Melhores disso tudo é sobre isso
que eu vim falar para vocês no dia de
hoje então eu quero focar e muita coisa
boa que tá acontecendo trazer algumas
reflexões e a primeira das reflexões
Exatamente Essa nós vínhamos falando
muito nos últimos anos sobre
inteligência artificial sobre
supercomputadores sobre Big deita e nada
disso no salvou nesse momento Então todo
esse desafio que nós vivemos nós estamos
superando com
o que estão ajudando outras pessoas
Esses são os heróis da nossa época então
a tecnologia é uma grande aliada mas
nesse momento com todos ineditismo com
tantas incertezas nós estamos cada vez
mais olhando para as pessoas o que é uma
coisa absolutamente incrível nós estamos
vivendo na prática o que nos últimos
anos chamou-se de transformação digital
e para muitas pessoas e muitas empresas
na verdade era uma perspectiva futura
tava em algum slide e agora nós vimos
tudo isso você colocar da prática então
é uma época que acelera tudo isso nos
traz para um futuro que era previsto e
muitos negavam agora todo mundo passou a
viver esse futuro então o que que eu
diria é que antes da pandemia como se
fosse um pêndulo ele tava embaixo a
velocidade no caminho da digitalização o
que que nós vivemos nesse período essa
aceleração o outro lado do pêndulo E por
que que eu acho que nós sairemos
Melhores disso tudo
e nós poderemos combinar o melhor de
cada um dos Mundos o mundo que havia
antes da pandemia com tudo que Nós
aprendemos dentro da pandemia Esse é o
futuro que nos aguarda um futuro de
Sabedoria de combinação de isso tudo o
que aconteceu nesse período foi que nós
descobrimos que a tecnologia tava muito
mais pronta do que nós imaginávamos
então o que que eu tô mostrando aqui a
curva amarela essa curva exponencial da
evolução tecnológica O problema é a
nossa curva absolutamente linear em
vagarosa de mudança de comportamento é a
nossa cabeça Então a partir da hora que
nós passamos a fazer eventos remotos nós
começamos a trabalhar pela internet
muitos ficaram surpresos mas na verdade
a grande surpresa é porque que nós já
não fazíamos isso porque que nós já não
usávamos tudo isso se tudo já estava
pronto A única coisa nova foi a doença o
resto já estava pronto então o desafio
que fica é manter essa motivação
mantém-se dinamismo manter essa
flexibilidade nas nós
e o que nós vimos nós passamos a
entender que uma série de preconceitos e
dogmas Que nós tínhamos foram quebrados
por exemplo que nós tivemos que fazer
com as crianças porque elas continuam
assim aprendendo muito falar não quero
uma coisa absolutamente impossível hora
ensinar a distância Isso é coisa que mal
se faz durante a faculdade e nós
conseguimos então é uma época de muita
transformação e Aqui nós temos algumas
pistas valiosas para todos nós Antes de
acontecer tudo isso vários professores
foram entrevistados EA pergunta foi você
acha que dá para ensinar crianças a
distância mais de oitenta por cento dos
respondentes falaram Não isso não
funciona só que a segunda pergunta é
muito interessante oitenta por cento
deles também afirmavam que não se sentir
um prontos para o ensino a distância e a
terceira pergunta Ainda mais incisiva
que esse professor já tinha em algum
momento da sua vida ensinado alguma
coisa pela internet e a resposta para
laje noventa porcento era não
bom então perceba que muitas vezes o
medo o medo que nós sentimos em relação
a mudança é fruto do nosso despreparo
falta de ambientação com a tecnologia E
aí Nós entramos no modo de defesa nós
começamos a fugir de sistemas estão nos
últimos anos nós sabíamos que a
tecnologia é inevitável que ela seria
uma grande parceira mas nós temos um
pouco de medo um pouco de medo por não
ter ambientação e o que que aconteceu
nesse momento uma forte ambientação
porque a tecnologia acabou salvando
negócios a forma como nós encontramos
para fazer uma série de coisa então esse
também é um aprendizado muito importante
nós quebramos Barreiras Como foi o caso
da telemedicina a telemedicina cresceu
mais do que o comércio eletrônico tem
muita muito foco nesse crescimento do
e-comerce das vendas pela internet a
grande revolução aconteceu na saúde
então isso já era esperado em alguma
medida nós temos muito mais pessoas com
smartphone na mão do que hospitais e
clínicas disponíveis porque não
e as pessoas dessa maneira para poder
levar informação e saúde nós sairemos
melhores isso tudo Além disso nós
trazemos conforto quantas vezes que um
paciente preciso de um retorno de um
exame conversar com o médico e muitas
vezes ele tem que se deslocar ele tem
que perder o trabalho passar por uma
dificuldade tremenda então isso já era
possível já era possível o que nós vimos
acontecer mais uma vez um crescimento
exponencial do e-comerce mas a coisa
mais relevante é o crescimento do Easy
service e o que que é isso a
possibilidade de prestar serviço à
distância então genuinamente nós estamos
vivendo uma era em que nós não temos
mais Barreiras geográficas nós podemos
fazer negócio com qualquer canto do
mundo porque é isso Que Nós aprendemos
de fato isso já tava pronto mas agora
nós temos estamos nós vimos durante os
períodos 70 mais de setenta por cento
dos consumidores trocando as suas marcas
preferidas Por que algumas marcas não
conseguiram fazer essa jornada a
transformação digital para poder
atendê-los
e na internet nós começamos aprender o
poder da conveniência cada vez mais o
quê que é conveniência são os negócios
as empresas que entendem que ele tem que
se voltar e integralmente para essa
centralidade do Consumidor afinal de
contas o inimigo do shopping não é o
e-commerce o inimigo do shopping muitas
vezes é a burocracia o trânsito a
dificuldade em enxergar Até lá então é
nós vivemos a saia de Hiper facilitação
em virtude da pandemia e isso fica
pessoas mais digitalizadas mais
exigentes e muito mais oportunidade com
muita transformação nos próximos anos o
que nós vimos foram pais mães se
tornaram Heróis o que nós vimos a
esperando foram as casas deixando de ser
casas e virando escritórios escolas um
ambiente absolutamente desafiador que as
pessoas tiveram que aprender a lidar com
isso nós vimos também um aceleração
desse debate extremamente rico e
importante sobre os limites
eu fiz da tecnologia mais uma vez
naquele movimento pendular nós achávamos
que cada vez mais tecnologia traria
coisas cada vez melhores e agora nós
começamos a entrar nessa onda nessa
época de mais maturidade e estamos
finalmente discutindo os dilemas das
redes esse excesso de uso de internet o
que que isso causa na nossa mente nós
estamos falando cada vez mais sobre a
info de Mia ficar muitas e muitas horas
conectados será que é isso que nós
precisamos ou será que nós precisaremos
cada vez mais essa conexão humana como
eu falei nesse momento nós ainda vivemos
uma série de restrições uma série de
impedimentos para poder viver do jeito
mais analógico que nós vivemos e daqui a
pouco nós vamos poder combinar o melhor
disso tudo então nós estamos
rejuvenescendo porque no final das
contas tem uma vida mais digital usar
essas ferramentas na nossa vida essa já
era a realidade desse Público aqui 10
bom então o que nós estamos vivendo a
pandemia uma possibilidade de oxigenar
nossa cabeça nós estamos vivendo coisas
que nós não viveríamos Por isso que eu
digo apesar da tristeza da doença é esse
período todo Nos fará pessoas melhores
com mais ferramentas com mais
possibilidades não podemos negar também
esse crescimento desse debate da
inclusão que há outro tema que tá tão
forte nesse momento tem um
imprescindível também imprescindível Por
que por vezes parece sim que o mundo é
feito só pelos jovens o que não é
verdade o que não é verdade e isso daqui
é especialmente importante para as
empresas porque elas tem que debater sim
cada vez mais a inclusão porque assim é
seu público de uma empresa só tem um
determinado perfil de profissional que
trabalha lá essa empresa criará produtos
e serviços só para essa parcela do
público sendo que o público é amplo e
diverso e precisa ser respeitado merece
respeitado muito mais do que as
classificações convencionais
a entender que o nome disso não é
inclusão é oportunidade então o mundo é
muito mais paradoxal do que parece nós
não podemos cair dos preconceitos rasos
que uma determinada geração é era muito
digital a outra é pouco digital o mundo
é muito mais paradoxal de parece muito
mais interessante essas classificações
elas não servem mais elas não funcionam
mais o que a pandemia trouxe é que todos
nós vamos colocar dentro de si mesmo
desafio da mesma maneira todos ficarão
frágeis todos ficaram expostos todos
tiveram que aprender e o aprendizado
sempre traz uma série de coisas muito
interessantes no segundo momento essas
classificações simplesmente a separação
por idade não faz sentido você nos que
lembrar que de um lado nós temos sim
mais pessoas digitais que afinal de
contas eles são os nativos digitais
desse lado direito da Imagem e nós temos
mais pessoas analógicas do lado esquerdo
mas só para dar medida do tamanho da
oportunidade nos Estados Unidos
e setenta por cento da riqueza dos
Estados Unidos está nos baby boomers ou
na geração chamada silenciosa que são as
pessoas com 70 75 anos a mais a geração
X tem 25 por cento e os millennials
Geração Z 5 porcento da Fortuna nos
Estados Unidos Então calma nós temos que
ter muita calma nessa compreensão dessa
transmissão digital para poder atender a
todos o que a pandemia trouxe foi uma
digitalização que traz produtividade uma
série de armadilhas porque a
produtividade do online nos faz viajar
menos mas de outra forma nos afasta da
serendipidade que são os encontros que a
vida atrás quantas vezes Nós aprendemos
em conversas informais em momentos que
não foram planejados e nesse momento nós
estamos hiper produtivos hiper focados
isso é um perigo hein nome da Inovação a
Inovação surge quando nós temos um pouco
mais de tranquilidade com a mente então
pouco mais relaxada e quando nós
conversamos
E é isso que nós temos que observar que
ficaram online para sempre certamente
não será uma alternativa nós viveremos
um mundo híbrido que será absolutamente
fantástico o mundo nos deu sinais de que
ainda dá tempo de recuperar muita coisa
ainda dá tempo essa foto eu achava
totalmente fantástica de um lado nós
temos délhi na nova délhi na Índia pré
pandemia e depois durante a pandemia
então isso na verdade é uma grande
celebração de que dá tempo sim dá tempo
nós teremos menos emissões Nós poderemos
ser cada vez melhores com o mundo então
o que esse período tá trazendo é um
fortalecimento um fortalecimento de
pessoas que entendem que nós teremos
cada vez mais Liberdade nós teremos cada
vez mais possibilidades com tudo isso E
para isso nós temos que ter
responsabilidade Essas são as
características dos profissionais do
Futuro São pessoas que entendem que o
empreendedorismo
bom então na nossa frente nós temos
menos caminhos certos e muito mais
possibilidades a serem criadas o que nós
estamos entendendo por isso que eu tô
tão animado com esse futuro que tá nossa
frente nós poderemos voltar a nos
abraçar nós poderemos é é para isso que
os seres humanos é para isso que os
seres humanos vivem Nós não fomos
criados para passarmos a nossas vidas
atrás de telas Nós não fomos criados
para ficar atrás de tela elas nos ajudam
mas nós temos a capacidade de sentir os
aromas de ver as paisagens de tocar as
pessoas de ficarmos emocionados é para
isso que o ser humano existe não para
ficar atrás de uma rede social ela é
benéfica até o momento que ela conecta e
ela se torna uma armadilha a partir do
momento em que ela começa a afastar nós
poderemos voltar para isso e os sinais
estão por toda a parte Então como é que
será esse mundo com vacinação com
proteção com a extinção espera-se
e essa doença tão terrível que surge
será um mundo em que as pessoas poderão
voltar a ter as suas vidas com muito
mais sabedoria uma vez mais e os sinais
estão por toda a parte muito falava que
seria um caos econômico pelo mundo
inteiro que as economias não retornariam
que o varejo não retornaria e o que que
aconteceu com essas foram as cenas que
nós vimos e porque eu fiz questão de
destacar uma loja de luxo Por que seria
contradição máxima essa daqui é uma loja
de luxo em que as pessoas estavam
fazendo fila para entrar e quando
entrevistadas escuta mais crise
econômica pandemia O que que você veio
fazer aqui e as pessoas respondiam
sorrindo eu precisava eu precisava disso
esse é o ser humano então o futuro é
muito mais positivo do que nós
conseguimos ver nesse momento nesse
momento e só para dar alguns ensaios
finais nós temos que lembrar que esses
grandes momentos de transformação Assim
como as grandes depressões econômicas as
guerras os momentos de instabilidade
a econômica e esse momento que nós
estamos vivendo tem uma mistura disso
tudo em virtude da doença o que acontece
é que na última década nós nos
debruçamos sobre essas empresas ditas
muito inovadoras Alguns chamam de
disruptivas Então se uma pessoa fosse
entrevistado por aquela citasse algumas
empresas inovadoras certamente no
cardápio muitas dessas apareceriam e se
vocês olharem O Elo em comum todas elas
foram criadas no ápice da última grande
crise antes da pandemia na crise de 2008
nos Estados Unidos que assolou o mundo
inteiro o que que esses momentos trazem
por quê que é tão especial participar de
um evento como esse com vocês aqui em
Cuiabá porque esses momentos trazem três
ingredientes o primeiro deles uma
revira-volta tecnológica que é
exatamente o que nós estamos vivendo uma
revira-volta dos hábitos dos consumos e
das crenças a forma como as pessoas
fazem as coisas e principalmente o
porquê que essas empresas foram criadas
é porque justamente no meio do
pessimismo quando as pessoas ficam
congeladas vencem os Corajosos vem seus
inovadores vencem as pessoas que têm
atitude vencem as pessoas que entendem
que simplesmente esperar que o mundo
volte a ser o que já foi um dia vou
ficar esperando o vento a favor não
resolve absolutamente nada nunca O Nosso
Tempo É absurdamente exibo nós vamos
fazer o melhor com ele sempre não é uma
alternativa ficar esperando as coisas
simplesmente passarem e é por isso que é
o ser humano precisa disso ele precisa
estar junto é esse futuro que nos
aguarda para coisas incríveis como
Exatamente esse momento que nós estamos
vivendo no Tex Senai Cuiabá
e é isso nós encontraremos cada vez mais
maturidade depois de passar por isso nós
teremos capacidade de impactar cada vez
mais pessoas usando a tecnologia ao
nosso lado mas nunca esquecendo como eu
comecei esse toque falando nós vínhamos
falando tanto da dominância da
tecnologia sobre o ser humano o que
ficou escancarado é que no final do dia
sempre sempre a solução a transformação
a mudança acontece pelas pessoas para as
pessoas
é obrigado a
E aí
[Música]